Let's talk about the strategy behind a killer introduction email.
Let's start with tip number one.
Tip number one: quickly introduce your name, location and title.
You don't need the backstory of why you picked up your first styling floral kit...
...or why you picked up your first camera.
Just tell me your name, where you're from, and your title.
In my case, I would say I'm Jasmine Star.
I'm a photographer from Newport Beach, California.
Get into it right quickly.
Number two: identify key details you like about their business.
So, you start it for the introduction and then you talk about them.
Why do you talk about them?
Well, it indicates that you are following what their business is doing.
And it could be by way of newsletters.
It could be by way of their YouTube channel or by way of social media.
The idea is secondly, identify more things about them...
...because you build trust right off the bat.